hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom live stream we have a exciting
i guess we could call it a show today uh
just to get everyone on the same page
what this thing even is if you're
showing up for the first time we're
doing these
live streams as a way to stay connected
during school closures uh when we
started seeing the school closures it
now seems a lifetime ago but it was i
guess it was four or five weeks ago we
realized that all of us at khan academy
with as a not-for-profit with a mission
of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere uh that we
had to step up and we had to figure out
how to support all of you as parents as
teachers and students as much as
possible so we started publishing things
like daily schedules to structure all of
the content on khan academy learning
plans teacher parent webinars and also
this home room and it's a place to talk
about everything
the closures themselves the economy
covet virus
many times just ask any questions you
have we have an awesome guest today i
encourage you it's going to be melody
hops and i'll give a better introduction
for in a few seconds but feel free to
start asking questions on the message
boards either for myself or for melody
especially i want to give everyone a
reminder we are not for profit we are
funded primarily through philanthropic
donations and so if you are in a
position to do so please think about
donating to khan academy we were already
running at a deficit before school
closures and now our traffic is almost
3x of what it typically is and you could
imagine we're trying to do more in the
in this context so if you're
for us to be able to do the work for
folks who might not be able to afford uh
anything is appreciated i do want to
give a special shout out to several
corporations who stepped up in the last
few weeks uh to really especially around
the coved response bank of america
fastly novartis google.org and at t
so with that i'm eager to have as much
time with our guest as possible i've
known our guest melody for some time
melody hobson is the co-ceo and
president of aerial investments
and you know there's two things i really
am eager to talk to you about melody one
is just your journey to becoming co-ceo
of what i think is one of the most
important investment firms in the world
uh and
uh your
your view of the economy you know we've
brought had a couple of folks on in the
investment management world and it's
just in interesting times to put it
lightly so so maybe a good place to
start melody
you know tell us there's a lot of young
people watching who are trying to figure
out their life what should they do with
their life tell us a little bit about
your journey how did you end up
becoming
the co-ceo of aerial investments
well thank you so much for having me on
sal and just know that i'm such a big
fan of yours as you know all too well
from the first time i came to see you i
told you i was just enamored by all the
things you were doing to teach so many
people all around the world and i
applaud your efforts and just feel so
much gratitude that you have things like
that that ex like this that exist for
people all over the world i'm also
honored to be asked to be
um one of the people that you interview
and to tell my story my story i think is
the story of many people um around the
world in so many ways just a story of
persistence and really really hard work
i grew up in chicago and i was the
youngest of six children my mom was a
single mom
and when i was growing up we had a
really at times
challenging existence to say the least
sometimes we got evicted sometimes our
phone got disconnected lights got cut
off we live in some of the abandoned
apartments that my mom used to try to
fix up and rent for people in order to
make a living
it is during that time that i became
clear that i was desperate to understand
money
not make it not have a lot understand it
i thought if i could understand money i
could have a better life and i really
committed myself to that
when i was 19 years old i had the
opportunity to be an intern at aerial
investments which was this fledgling
investment firm started by this
wonderkid named john rogers who started
the company when he was 24 years old
today we're 37 years old now
and after i graduated from college i
went back and worked at the firm in 1991
after graduating from princeton
and i've only had one job since then
and i started off on the client services
and marketing side learning everything i
could learn about investing in the stock
market and over time rose up in the
organization
in may of 2000 i became president i went
from intern to president
and then last summer in 2019 i became
co-ceo
it's an amazing story in so many ways
and i have so much gratitude for the
opportunity i've been given but most of
all i have the most amount of gratitude
for what i've been able to learn about
money and investing
over this near 30-year career that i've
been doing this and how that is really
uh putting me a fire
to teach what i know to other people so
that they can have a better life
and what's your sense what do you think
made your trajectory so successful what
do you think were the traits in it
that made you a successful investor uh
and allowed other people to recognize it
as well
well i think the first thing that helped
me was that i always believed that you
have to always be learning always than i
ever have felt even today that i know
enough and that i can stop
and so having that open mind some people
call it a beginner's mind that's a
buddhist concept that your mind is
always new like a child and you're
approaching everything from the
perspective of a beginner allows you to
um really take in a lot of information
ray kroc who started mcdonald's had a
quote that i really liked where he says
you know as long as you're green you
grow when you're ripe you rot
and i really like that concept of just
staying green all the time and being
open
not being so convinced that you know
everything i think that made a
difference secondly a commitment to
learning we call ourselves a learning
culture at ariel we always want to build
on what we learned from before so right
now being in this global pandemic we're
building on all the knowledge we learned
in the financial crisis of 2008 and 9.
and then during that period we built on
the things that we learned in 9 11
and that we built on things we learned
in the crash of 87 so it's like
constantly accumulating knowledge that
will make you better better and building
on it so you have more and more muscle
memory
and the last thing is just i love the
idea of learning about the markets
talking about companies really
understanding how money works around the
world it just really fascinates me and
so i think it's very important you you
become more successful at something that
you really like
and i just really love the business that
i'm in and at the end of the day i tell
our team that we work with we get to
make people's lives better because we
grow their money in their pension fund
or their kids college education money
that's in our mutual funds whatever it
might be so that they can have a better
outcome and that's as fulfilling as
anything that anyone could do as
fulfilling as you teaching be as
fulfilling as doctors who are doing what
they do we feel that our work is that
important
and we're getting a lot of questions off
of youtube and social media which is
great uh for adithya gupta and this is a
good starter question you know a lot of
people are kind of vaguely familiar okay
there are these things these investment
funds but his question is what what does
aerial investments do and maybe i'll
extend his question
what is the date what is your day like
and and maybe what is it like when you
started
what is an investment manager an analyst
do
so
let's start off with aerial investments
does we are
a boutique independent
money management company we manage stock
portfolios for big institutions so think
states
cities
foundations
a whole host of organizations often
pension but it could be endowment money
as well
and then for individuals we have
publicly traded mutual funds that anyone
can invest with us who has as little as
50 a month to put in our mutual funds
we buy domestic companies u.s companies
that are small and medium-sized
companies that are out of favor but show
a strong potential for growth and over
the years we've owned everything from
companies that you know they usually
dominate the niche that they're in
everything from smuckers jelly which is
in the portfolio right now in the past
we've owned things like tiffany's the
retailer and clorox the the
diversified consumer products company so
you name it those companies the
dominated niche we say once you get the
customer they go back again and again
small and medium-sized companies
and then we have international and
global portfolios international means
it's only companies based outside of the
united states and global means it's
companies all over the world including
the united states and those portfolios
also seek to invest in companies that
are out of favor and that's everything
from
higher companies
to uh
the version of
of what you would have in america with
some of our internet businesses that are
based in china like baidu so
we're looking for these brands and
franchises and we want businesses that
will be able to grow over time but we
want to buy them when they're out of
favor when for whatever reason they've
been cast aside so as you might imagine
right now during a time when the stock
market has been so volatile there have
been a lot of buying opportunities that
have come to us so these days were super
busy when you ask about my day i am
actually not an investment analyst
although i am
someone whose rolodex is used on a
regular basis to inform the stocks that
we are buying so in this current
environment i've been on the phone on
many occasions with my co-ceo calling
friends in the industry talking about
what they're seeing in the market
because we can learn from everyone
including we called his old corporate
finance teacher someone named bert
malkiel who wrote a book called the
random walk down wall street that is so
famous i think it's in its ninth edition
say what do you think of this
environment but we'll also call very
famous money managers and ask them that
as well but we do our own independent
work in our own independent thinking but
we can learn from anyone and then our
team would be spending lots of time on
the phone talking to management teams of
companies that we own
asking them what their prospects for the
business are what has changed what is
the same how are they managing through
the period and most important of all
do they have the liquidity to get them
to the other side
and i say the other side because this
will end at some point it won't be
forever
at some point there will be a vaccine at
some point we will go back to life as we
know it
we don't know how long that will be and
so the most important thing is to
understand from those companies that
they have the balance sheet and the
wherewithal to be without to be able to
withstand whatever kind of pain they
will feel during this period
i spend an enormous amount of time on
the phone talking to our clients and
shareholders
writing to them writing the
communications explaining what we're
doing so that they're as informed as
possible and they're no surprises when
it comes to our portfolios and how we're
investing and performing
and
you're touching on i think where a lot
of the questions are which are
where's the economy going but before i
go in that there's something you said
that's interesting i think a lot of
people could learn from you know the
fact that you're looking at companies
that are out of favor uh that might be
counterintuitive for some so
where is what's the hypothesis there and
also i'm fascinated by your logo which
is a turtle so
and maybe those two things are connected
well we believe that real money is made
over time and all of our beliefs come by
come from studying the investment grades
the ingress the greatest investor of our
modern time is warren buffett
the ceo and chairman of berkshire
hathaway who still happens to be alive
who is one of the greatest track records
in investing of any human being ever
and so we've thought a lot about what
he's written about and talked about and
he talks about time is the friend
of uh the wonderful investor the enemy
of the mediocre
and so we think about that fact that we
want to invest in things that over the
long term will demonstrate
growth and there may be a reason that
it's temporary out of favor maybe an
entire industry got taken down at once
and a good company went down with it and
so we're looking for those those
opportunities to be able to buy
companies when forever reason something
has gone wrong so a simple example of
that we've been buying buying a company
recently that's in the dental industry
and that's very much of late and the
reason that it's compelling is because
we say to ourselves okay
we get it when you're sheltered in place
no one can go to the dentist so the
earnings and revenue on that business
just fall off a cliff there's no
question about it then our next question
is can they manage through this period
for a significant period of time not
knowing when it'll be over their best in
class at what they do
and when things get up and running again
we believe most people will go back to
the dentist in fact there'll probably be
some pent-up demand there so that would
be an example of out of favor but shows
potential for long-term growth when you
think of around the world more and more
people go to the dentist i'll give you
another quick example medical related we
own a company called zimmer that makes
hips and knees
and they literally it's the a doctor
gets trained on one device and they use
that device all the time so it's in our
mind a razor razor blade business the
doctor is the razor the customer is the
razor blade so the customer comes
through and gets tips and knees over and
over again again during this pandemic no
elective surgery having a bad hip or
knee doesn't kill you
but it might really hurt so people can't
go to the doctor and get their hip
replaced but we're looking at the
demographics that show this very basic
math that shows baby boomers are going
to need hips and knees for every one
pound you gain it's four pounds on your
knees so while again there may not be
surgeries right now over time not only
will it recover but we say that's going
to unfortunately be a growing industry
so that's what we mean about buying
things we're not with that when they're
out of favor
no it's very compelling
who don't know my old job i was an
analyst at a at a hedge fund at a much
more junior level than melody but my
boss always used to say you know when
you're buying there's someone smart
selling to you and when you're selling
there's someone smart buying so what do
you think your edge is and melody's edge
it sounds like it's very much aligned
with the warren buffets of the world is
that most people think relatively short
to medium term and kind of move with the
herd and move with emotion and if you
can somehow separate yourself from that
and be a little bit contrarian sometimes
you might be able to time could be your
friend
and that speaks to our logo and we'd say
be a lot contrarian the number of calls
that i've gotten from everything from
working class individuals who are trying
to make ends meet saying my 401k plan or
fourth weekly plan is getting crashed
the billionaires that we work for who
say i'm thinking of selling you don't
sell into the panic buffett has this
quote by the panic there's another
famous line you want to be greedy when
others are fearful and fearful when
others are greedy so during a time of
fear and panic indiscriminate selling
which we saw in early march we're going
to be thinking where are the
opportunities again there's that famous
line i think it's churchill who said
don't let an opera a crisis go to waste
and so that you say during that crisis
just from an investment standpoint what
are the opportunities that might just be
being thrown away where people are just
running for cover which is actually the
rope you should never sell into that
kind of down market that's why we have a
turtle as a logo and we talk about slow
and steady winning the race like aesop's
fable and don't get the sense that we
mean slow and being like we're not doing
anything we are urgently patient like we
are looking for opportunities at all
time we take our time and we're thinking
of what will this company be over the
next three to five years not the next
three to five quarters
i like that phrase urgently patient i
think i need to be a little bit more of
that myself
i have the urgency i need the more more
of the more of the patients so that's
really what we are we're urgently
patient we're looking at it with urgency
but we're taking a long-term view about
what it'll be that's great and we're
getting a ton of questions you can
imagine about the economy itself and you
know those those businesses that you
just talked about make a ton of sense at
least even with my old investment hat on
but a lot of people and we had ray dalio
on last week and you know the there's
kind of contrasting trends here we saw
the market go down a lot and then it's
kind of gone back up uh to a reasonable
level it seems
to me as someone who's not doing this as
my day job anymore that the market got
reasonably optimistic maybe once we hit
the peak of the crisis and things like
that
but on the other hand when you look at
the jobless claims numbers you you think
about well even if a state does open up
will people really go to restaurants or
dentists or whatever else it could be a
while
how
do you think the market has it wrong do
you think
there's something else at play here
what's y'all's macro read
so we are bottom up stock pickers so
we're looking at companies just one
company at a time what will it be over
the long term and we like it best when
those companies don't get uh you know
beaten up and down by what's going on
from a macro perspective but in this
environment that's unavoidable what we
would say is that we we don't think of
the market as being right or wrong it
just is
and so from that perspective our work is
to try to be thoughtful around what is
occurring
and the market what it typically does it
anticipates the future it looks out into
the future
and and has some sense of what it thinks
will happen and that's obviously as a
result of a cluster of people buying and
selling etc and there's no question with
the recover we've seen in such a short
period of time the market is
anticipating
better days ahead for the economy
perhaps they're they're thinking the
recovery will be faster than what
everyone thought in early march when
shares were being indiscriminately sold
and so we would say that is what it is
it could be wrong we might have a w
where we
go down again we may have stayed home
orders again in the fall we don't know
we have thought more that it might look
more like a you
that we'd have this period through the
rest of the year where you would not
expect a lot out of corporate america
especially in terms of profitability or
earnings and then you'd start to see a
recovery in 2021 which to us is like a
nanosecond in investing
that is the scenario with which we're
working against but we can be wrong and
still be right because remember we're
thinking long term and we're not making
investments we're not trading based upon
the next three to six months
it's nice to be have the market recover
the way it has but we also know that it
has been a very very volatile period and
these things can turn turn on the dime
turn on a dime i think our biggest
concern right now is if we come out way
too fast and way too early that people
you know could be in a situation where
if they have to lock down again that
might be very very upsetting so we will
just have to play it by ear and see here
and for us it's really to take advantage
of the opportunities as they come
and these businesses like say these are
associated with the dental industry or
hip replacement that
when you are in a stay in place order or
maybe even once we're out of the stay in
place order uh and you're allowed to go
but most people will try not to go until
there's a vaccine or something how long
when you're looking at how long they can
be solvent with you know little revenue
what what time horizon are you all
looking at is it six months eighteen
months we were looking at yeah
we were looking at the next six to 12
months yes and saying if they're really
really compromised during that period
will these businesses do they have the
balance sheet that they can be okay
that's the question we're asking
ourselves and that's not a yes for
certain industries i mean we're going to
see bankruptcies come out of this
environment we've already started to see
that and there are whole sectors that
are really really taking it on the chin
i mean it's
you know the airline industry is going
to be compromised there's no question
about it because that's an industry
where capital expenditures are very very
expensive you've got big labor issues
now they're benefiting from loyal lower
oil prices but there are a whole bunch
of things that can hit them and so that
would be an industry that we'd say we
just don't we don't we don't know
what'll happen there that goes into the
too hard category for us but there'll be
a whole bunch of other areas where you
can again look out and say
literally
you know i know like if my crown breaks
i'm going to the dentist but you know
it's just it's not going to be a
question
yeah and i know y'all are bottoms up and
actually the fund i used to work for was
very very similar to a much smaller
scale but i am i'm sure you do have a
view on uh i mean you just gave a little
bit of view on the macro but what from a
policy point of view if you were the
chairman of the federal reserve or if
you were the treasury secretary
do do what what kind of actions you
think need to be taken or not taken to
get us through this
well i have to say i applaud what they
have done so far i was in a board
meeting with someone and they said
the federal reserve didn't bring a
bazooka they brought the whole arsenal
and that is true this is a giant
contrast to the 0809 financial crisis
when i remember hank paulson who was
then treasury secretary going and
presenting to congress and asking for a
stimulus build that was 750 billion
dollars and then initially turning him
down and he didn't needed that money to
rescue american banks
and that was one of those daunting
moments the market just literally
cratered on that bad news this is just
the opposite congress has an open
checkbook which has its own
repercussions potentially down the road
but today you want to be in the business
of doing too much versus too little and
they're approaching this in exactly that
manner now that said i want those
stimulus texts to get to individuals
faster because that has been problematic
um at certain levels and i think the
small business um ppp
is also uh challenged in terms of how
fast people are getting money and are is
everyone getting that equal access to
the opportunity to participate so those
things i think we've got to get on the
one thing i'll also say they did a
really good job with the furlough
situation that when employees get
furloughed they're getting their full
compensation which um incense companies
not to lay those people off
and so i think that's really really good
and i think the unemployment benefits
given the number of people who've had to
file claims at the end of the day i
think they did the right thing um there
as well and especially with putting on
the extra for children and there was a
lot there that was i think very very
thoughtful
and um and the right thing to do i just
don't think it's over i think we're
looking at more stimulus not less
and there's tons of questions here but
one follow-up question to that what do
you think are the long-term implications
to your point
you know in times of emergence you can
think in very fundamental terms there is
food out there we just need to make sure
people have currency to buy the food
their shelter we need to make sure they
have currency to pay that rent but in
order to do so you know trillions of
dollars potentially of increasing the
the debt
what what do you think are the long-term
implications if any
inflation is likely a long-term
implication i mean when we've talked to
a number of experts out there and
academics they're pretty united in their
point of view um when rome is burning
you know if your house is burning down
you're not thinking about the rebuild at
that point you're thinking about putting
out the fire so right now we're still in
the put out the fire mode and then we'll
have to figure out the the
environment afterwards and what we do
about that
but again i think there's no other
action that could be taken than the
actions that have been taken thus far
yeah now we have this question from uh
tamika rogers on youtube and you've
touched on this already uh but i'll ask
it again because i'm sure a lot of
people are asking this miss hobson is
this the perfect time to invest in the
stock market well-known companies mostly
that you i guess she's asking would it
be well-known companies mostly that you
expect to thrive in two to five years
which does sound
aligned with y'all's thinking
so this is what i would say first of all
um
i do think there are some
opportunities out there not as many as
there were a month ago when things were
worse
but what i would say you know warren
buffett says it's a market of stocks not
a stock market so there are companies
always for sale in the stock market even
when the stock market is at highs
i would caution people to make sure they
have the right perspective and i think
you have to take a longer term view and
not to expect this to be like a rubber
band that's recoiled and it just bounces
back like that so just making sure again
you're looking out and you're patient
in your perspective i also would
encourage you to invest in things you
know that's a famous line from another
great investor value investor named
peter lynch who was very famous in the
80s and he talked about you know
investing within investing in things
that you have a good sense of as opposed
to trying to stretch and and learn
something that that you don't know or
understand there's certain areas we
don't invest in because we do not
understand them and we think we're smart
but we tend not to buy commodities
because you have to predict them there
are a whole host of things we don't have
a lot of exposure to technology
um because we think there's rapid
obsolescence especially along among
smaller and mid-sized technology
companies
that you know you can be
put out of business very quickly by
another competitor or disrupted very
easily and then your value could erode
it's harder for google now or harder for
facebook but some of this on the smaller
end that can be challenging so we don't
tend to do a lot there being very
realistic about what you know and
understand i'm not one for tips stock
tips from people anything like that and
if you don't have the stomach for this
don't do it get a professional by mutual
funds
that you have investment professionals
like us at ariel that are actually doing
the work and worrying about this on a
day-to-day basis
and actually just a curious question
something i always struggled with when i
was in the same field is you have a
strong thesis you've done your homework
you've made your investment
and y'all are famously patient about it
but i'm sure well my question is are
there sometimes that you are unsure
about yourself and do you have you
how do you draw the line between
doubling down on your bet versus saying
maybe i was just wrong and getting out
of it and obviously there's parallels to
life there but you're living it every
day in the investment world
so first we have this point that we make
with our investment team and we say we
hold our ideas lightly not dearly
so we hold them lightly so that we have
the ability with new information to
change our minds it's very important
because investing you don't need a as
again quoting buffett a perfect batting
average to be successful
and so as a result of that you're going
to make mistakes you must accept that
one of the greatest pieces of advice i
got was my from my co-ceo and business
partner once i was agonizing over
something and he said you know melody i
don't agonize over mistakes because i
make them frequently and you really have
to have a little bit of a move on
mentality you make it what did you learn
from it and you move on and there are
times we've absolutely made mistakes and
we want to internalize those lessons
one of the periods where we made
mistakes was in 2008-2009
where we underperformed for the first
time in a down market and we
underperformed significantly and we went
back and completely overhauled our
balance sheet work
and how we were doing it and making sure
companies had the wherewithal for tough
periods and we think that those
learnings allowed us to survive this
period and endure this period much
better than we did before as an example
and so we make mistakes with stocks all
the time and the simple question we ask
our analysts this is the easy way to
think about it
we don't allow our analyst to say hold
some companies you have a buy a hold or
a sell we say you're either a buyer or a
seller
you must pick if you don't want to buy
it you want to sell it and in some ways
that's figurative to us for us but it's
a way of making people really put a
stake in the ground you either like it
or you don't you can't live in this this
no man's land of hold without you know
showing your hand of what you really
believe
that's a fascinating point because
i've always thought about it but it
never phrased the way you just said
because your your point is right if
you're holding something you're
essentially saying if you were buying
today you'd be willing to buy it
because great
definition holding that's that's a
fascinating thing the rest of the
industry
i think a lot of folks are
seeking shelter in that hold position
because you can't be too right and the
thing is we have to affirm that every
day
that's the thing you you can't you can't
rationalize that because you've owned it
for this you know whatever amount of
time again quoting a great investor the
stock doesn't know you own it it doesn't
care
so every day you're starting off with
the idea that is this better than owning
something else it doesn't matter how
long i owned it before
and i really love you know that idea of
not holding your ideas too tightly i
think there's a very big meta wisdom to
that you know even in life our egos can
get very attached to our points of views
or our ideas
and sometimes even become destructive in
our lives because we hold tight so
tightly to them in the face of new
information so there's something very
zen about that
think about that from the perspective
just politics today and the polarization
of ideas around political
uh parties etc that when people become
too
wedded to an ideology it can break down
you know real progress
and so we really do have this
perspective of that's one of the reasons
we believe diverse points of view are so
imp important to solving really hard
problems and bringing people with all of
those diverse points of view that might
have a point of view that's very strong
but again that i'm willing to yield my
perspective to a more compelling point
of view as opposed to
um just being wedded to an ideology
yeah no i mean that's so relevant on so
many levels uh there's a question here
about
finance and gender or learning uh
finance from aditya gupta from youtube
how can we learn to start
how can we learn how to start learning
about finance investing and the economy
at a younger age how can we start
investing at our ages
so first and foremost this is one of the
things that just
you know sal i came to see you on this
topic because the thing that frustrates
me so much is that i'm just going to use
america as the base for the conversation
here
you can go to high school in america
today and take wood shop or auto and not
a class on investing
which always leads me to ask audiences
the same thing who's whittling in their
spare time who's cleaning their own
carburetor no one right but when it
comes to understanding the basics of the
dow the s p the nasdaq you know small
cap make up large cap market
capitalization growth value all of these
things that have some
profound
um potential effect on your long-term uh
financial security we don't teach it and
so that's why opportunities like this
are so important what i believe very
strongly is that investing should be
caught taught in school in america at a
very young age i think it should be like
learning a language i have a
six-year-old and she takes spanish at
school she already speaks chinese and
once you can start early you become very
facile in the language and i think
that's very very important
one way if you can't get it in a school
to get them to have it as part of the
curriculum and i say to people if you
have a stock broker a financial advisor
the person in the local bank that may
know something about investments maybe
they can come in and teach a class for
your nephew or your child or what have
you do you get a sense of these
important concepts um that the children
get a sense of these important concepts
if you can't do that i think a great
idea is to do what john rogers my
business partner's father did for him
his father was a child of the depression
an orphan he moved to chicago when he
was 11 years old he was in the first
class of tuskegee airmen and he wanted
john to understand money and so he gave
john stocks every birthday and every
christmas starting when he was 12 years
old instead of toys now you may not do
the instead of toys part but certainly
having that component be a part of his
gift giving really taught john from the
very beginning the fundamentals of
investing and you can do that with a
child by giving them gifts of stock of
things that they know and like and
that's the gift that keeps giving versus
the top the toy that becomes obsolete at
some point and that could be mattel that
could be shares of sony because of
playstation that could be mcdonald's or
nike things that the children understand
fundamentally or your teen and
ultimately may create some interest
there that they can watch and understand
the benefits of ownership and equity as
opposed to just consumer consumerism
yeah that's a powerful idea
i actually think it's talking about
edges that i think some younger people
because they think a little bit
different have a different lens they
actually might be able to uh have a
perspective that uh professionals might
not even fully fully have uh there
there's a question here from
leyla torres it's really praised but i
think it leads to a question melody
thanks for being a role model to all
females in finance we don't have many
and it was great to learn about you and
the question i'll ask is why don't we
see more females in finance
i think there's a lot of stigma around
issues related to math and girls and you
know i'm not the first person who's ever
said this and it's disappointing and it
it it continues to exist and it's true
and that therefore
affects our ranks in both the investment
business as well as in engineering and
other areas and i think it's a
perception that's just wrong the data
shows it so we've looked at the
investment habits patterns and successes
of women versus men and interestingly
women tend to be better investors
part of the reason that we tend to be in
better investors we tend to trade less
and be more patient
and that ultimately works in our benefit
and they've looked at lots and lots of
decisions that have been made over time
to be able to show that now that's just
rank and file people in their personal
investment portfolios in the industry
then i'm in only seven percent of
portfolio managers or women we actually
have one in my office that's a great
investor named rupaul bonsali who
manages our international and global
strategies and has done a phenomenal job
but it's it's really
disappointing to see those numbers
haven't moved very much no i think
exposure is part of that they need to
see people like rupaul and people like
me who love what we do and are in this
business and in it to win it and i think
to the extent that girls and teens and
college students are aware of the
opportunities in our industry and the
fulfillment that we get from the work
that we do i think they would be as
excited about it as we are
and related to that another comment this
is from rishika
tsalam seti from youtube said melody
hops and you are so inspiring to all
girls around the world i'm a girl of
color and i'm really inspired by you and
that kind of going with the question
from laila
you know when you went into the industry
right out of college and you looked
around it probably were even fewer women
even fewer people of color
what
did you ever feel like hey how come
there's no one like me maybe i don't
belong or and how did you overcome any
feelings like that
so
i'm smiling because i had a friend once
that i asked a question about you know
being different in the industry etc and
he was like melody how long have you
been black
how long have you been a woman you know
it just comes with the territory when
you're a woman or a person of color you
understand what you're up against i've
told stories about how when i was a
young girl my mother told me what i
would be up against and she explained to
me i have it in my ted talk that people
won't always treat me well she told me
that when i was six years old and it was
really something that was very important
because it allowed me not to then be
defeated by any form of inequity that i
saw
i saw the opportunity when i entered the
industry in 1991 to be different and so
i joke with people when i would go to
investment conferences i would be the
only one the only woman of color and
when i go up to people they'd say your
melody before they'd even met me and i
could have been like cher or beyonce
like no last name i stood out
and so i used that standing out to my
advantage i said okay there's no one
else like me that i'm going to be
memorable as opposed to seeing it as a a
cross that i was carrying on my back it
doesn't mean that it was always easy by
any stretch of the imagination the way
that i built up my confidence is through
knowledge
the more
knowledge i have the more prepared i am
the more confident i am and i think
that's really important we all know what
it takes for us to walk into a room and
feel confident if i was studied in my
subject i could walk in with my head
high and with my ideas ready to go and i
think that's a very very important um
way of conquering um the world when you
can go in with good ideas and not be
afraid to say what they are not be
discouraged when they're rejected
um i always felt like i could get
another job that was the other thing i
was like if it doesn't work out here i'm
fully confident in myself
not because i'm cocky or have a huge ego
i just know i'll do whatever it takes if
tomorrow you told me i couldn't go work
at ariel and i had to go and work at
neiman marcus or macy's or uh kohl's or
you name the store i'd be the number one
sales person without a doubt because i
would do it with that much as much
passion as i do this proudly
so i really think it's about your own
mindset and your own mentality there are
going to be haters they exist everywhere
a big and small in your own race and
your own gender
and they're going to be people who root
for you and help you i just i've decided
to ignore those who weren't there to
help me try to avoid them as much as
possible make choices that would lead me
to people who are more positive and more
interested in a better outcome for me
and and that doesn't mean i got it
perfectly but more often than not by
giving people the benefit of the doubt i
was more right than wrong
wow that's incredibly inspiring and i
think
everyone you know everyone has aspects
about their being that they might feel a
little bit different than others or feel
impostor or feel insecure about certain
things but i think the way you framed it
right now is uh inspiring for for
everyone
uh melody i i could keep going for hours
asking you questions and and it looks
like youtube and facebook could keep
going hours as well but i want to be
very sensitive to your time thank you so
much for for joining this and i hope you
join again hopefully you had a good time
there's a lot of questions from a lot of
folks here uh but this was a really
inspiring conversation thank you so much
well thank you for having me and i just
really want to end by thanking you for
all the work you do sal for so many you
are one of my heroes i mean that
genuinely in my heart and i'm just so
proud to know you and to be able to
learn from you
well you're one of my heroes and uh it's
only been reinforced from this
conversation so i'm extra flattered that
you even say that but thank you so much
melody it was a real treat
so everyone thanks for uh joining uh
what i found to be a very inspiring
conversation uh with with melody uh a
lot of takeaways that i'm going to be
thinking about as i you know uh
i have my own uh i think we all have our
own things that we we deal with in life
but i i just loved uh melody's ability
to power through and be resilient and
optimistic and and in the face of
sometimes significant adversity uh but
anyway uh thanks for joining i hope we
can have melody on in the future as well
uh we're gonna have some other amazing
guests in the next few days and weeks uh
and you know stay safe stay healthy in
these times of uh of
uh and remind and just remind remind
yourself that we're all in this together
uh don't try to focus too much on some
of the negatives that you hear in the
news there's a lot of positives out
there uh and you know one of the silver
linings is we are seeing a lot of
humanity step up and do the right thing
i'll also just throw out the plug again
because it's part of my job we are not
for profit if you're in a position to do
so uh please think about making a
donation to khan academy's donations
like that that allow us to continue to
do this this work especially for folks
who might not otherwise be able to to
have access to learning materials
so thank you so much and i will see you
tomorrow
you